and our next artist has been up for four  Grammys he's also won an Oscar and his  work helped take home a Tony Glen  Hansard broke through by singing with  the Irish rock band the frames he  starred in a hit movie once and won the  Academy Award for best song that film of  course later became the Tony winning  musical Hansard just released his third  solo effort between two shores and  begins a world tour this month and now  to perform his new single here is Glen  Hansard and his 11 piece band with  wheels on fire  [Music]  you're one to talk until all the talk is  gone  [Music]  but you're not saying  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  don't go away we'll be right back with  more music someone answer